pour l'instant les vaccins contre le coc
u19 disponibles sur le marché sont
chinois britanniques russes ou encore
américains ce sont ces derniers qui ont
été validés par l' agence européenne des
médicaments est acheté par l'union
européenne qui s'est offert des millions
de doses des vaccins des laboratoires
pfizer bio in tech et son concurrent
moderne mais où est passé le vaccin
contre locaux vides 19 français tout de
suite
éléments de réponse dans facture en
france deux laboratoires sont en
capacité de faire un vaccin contre le
coc u19
le géant pharmaceutique sanofi et
l'institut pasteur
l'institut pasteur a toujours été avant
gardiste en termes de recherche
c'est d'ailleurs louis pasteur qui est
l'inventeur du vaccin contre la rage
soit le premier vaccin à avoir été
administré à l'homme
en 1885 oh bien sûr louis pasteur et
qu'un grand bond en histoire des vaccins
quelque part on d'un héritage assez
important alors comment expliquer le
retard de l'institut pasteur alors que
la france est le pays du vaccin ror peut
pas dire que cette cette oeuvre tard
spécifiquement française les vaccins
moderna et faïza sont basées sur les
technologies dites de l'aérés messager
qui n'est pas complètement nouvelle qui
est une technologie qui a qui a commencé
à être développée à partir de 1990 mais
la technologie est prête
le retard français s'explique tout
d'abord par un manque de moyens
techniques france on n'avait pas de
technologie qui étaient prêtes à
l'emploi si je puis dire aussi
rapidement et une des raisons en fait
c'est aussi parce que il est très
difficile d'avoir des financements pour
vraiment faire un développement de
recherche et développement de nouveaux
vaccins de nouvelles plateformes de
vaccin parce que ça très très très cher
et effectivement quand on se penche sur
le devis pour faire un vaccin
les montants sont exorbitants vous
donner un ordre de grandeur peu d'essais
cliniques de phase 1 qui va inclure
quelques dizaines de sujets quand
quelque chose de rentrer 3 à 4 le monde
euros un décès de cliniques de phase ii
qui inclut des centaines de gènes coûte
quelque chose entre 5 et 15 millions
d'euros et les phases 3 ça peut coûter
au moins de gens que les fonds du
ministère de la recherche ont été
débloqués pour l'institut pasteur de
lille
heureusement l'institut avec des bases
de construction pour le rex au travail
depuis longtemps sur un nouveau vaccin
contre la coqueluche c'est dans l'axé
nasal qui qu'il n'est pas injecté dans
le muscle comme les autres vaccins mais
qui est initié par esprit et dans libé
donc en ce qui concerne le coc vite
évidemment on s'est basés un peu sur la
même sur la même idée qu vite c'est une
maladie qui se transmet également par la
respiration tout au début de
déconstruction évidemment on est
beaucoup en retard car un pauvre ou
vaccin moderna et médecins foyer de
l'autre côté du ring le vaccin sanofi
est lui aussi en phase de recherche
mais pour le groupe pharmaceutique
français la lenteur du développement
pour le vaccin contre le coc u19 est un
peu plus complexe
pourquoi la france puis pasteur pourquoi
la france pourquoi sanofi n'a pas son
vaccin
ses dirigeants ont licencié la moitié de
leurs chercheurs la moitié donc sanofi
était de toute façon partie avec
quelques mois de retard au niveau 2 de
ces essais cliniques
sanofi a fait le choix de partir avec
deux projets de vaccins sont les seuls
un projet de vaccin à base d'arn
messager est une autre technologie
beaucoup plus éprouvé beaucoup plus
ancienne à base de protéines
recombinantes
l'argument majeur de sanofi c'est dire
on ne sera pas les premiers mais on
arrivera avec une technologie éprouvée
avec un vaccin efficace tout d'abord la
recherche pour son vaccin à base d'une
protéine recombinante développer aux
côtés du groupe britannique gsk s'avère
être plus compliqué que prévu
lors des essais cliniques de ce candidat
vaccin les antigènes était sous dosés
d'après le groupe
ce qui explique son manque d'efficacité
sur les personnes plus âgées
ils vont démarrer le mois prochain deux
nouveaux essais cliniques avec une
concentration en antigènes supérieur il
ya eu grand
grande déception ensuite le gouvernement
et plus précisément le ministère de
l'industrie a proposé au laboratoire
français de fabriquer le vaccin de
pfizer biotech
c'est une demande controversée puisque
ça revient à demander à san officiel de
devenir le sous traitant de son
concurrent
alors pour le moment il indique que ça
prendrait plusieurs mois
adaptez-vous ses chaînes de production
et qu'ils ne savent pas encore quel est
le la faisabilité de ce projet et qui il
ne désespère pas de lancer des essais
cliniques de phase iii au deuxième
semestre
il faudrait évidemment pas que ces deux
calendriers se télescopent en leur
défaveur parce que disons déjà
suffisamment de retard enfin deux
groupes annoncé lundi 18 janvier le
licenciement de 400 postes dans la
branche en recherche et développement
la direction du laboratoire confirme que
les services de recherche autour du
vaccin sont épargnés seule la fille me
seraient touchés sanofi est embarqué
dans un un processus de redynamisation
de sa r&d et de renouvellement de
l'entreprise de façon générale comme
sanofi assez au mois décembre un retard
sur sur l'un de ces deux projets de
vaccins ça ne passe pas bien
du point de vue des syndicats ce sont
les plans sociaux du groupe qui cause le
retard de la production du vaccin
donc on continue en fait à démanteler la
recherche et développement en france et
ensuite on s'étonnera qu'on ait pas de
vaccin ou de médicaments à mettre sur le
marché français et mondial c'est quand
même assez paradoxal ce qui explique le
retard de sanofi dans la course au
vaccin
c'est une stratégie qui a été engagé et
un accident industriel qui est survenu
malheureusement pour eux cette échelle
du vaccin souligner le manque de moyens
on recherchait développement et la fuite
des cerveaux français
regardez le nombre de projets de grande
qualité qui ont été envoyés à l'état par
cette agence nationale de la recherche
qu'on appelle la nerfs et le nombre de
projets qui ont été retenus pour
financement
eh bien il ya le grand grande différence
est là il ya un grand bang mans force
est de constater que le budget en
recherche et développement français n'a
cessé de décliner
puis 2014 et un projet de loi datant du
21 novembre 2019 fait également le
constat inquiétant de manque de moyens
omniprésent depuis 30 ans alors le
gouvernement a toujours du mal à mettre
la main au portefeuille
nello - la france est quand même à la
pointe de la recherche dans l'option
biomédical ou dans d'autres domaines
comme la physique par exemple est quand
même un certain nombre de prix nobel
l'omc qui est la consécration maximale
dans le domaine de la recherche donc il
ya un paradoxe
imaginez vous si les français avaient
plus de moyens pour fonctionner ce que
ça de vrai
[Musique]